foreign
we're approaching that time of year when
a third of a billion people all
residents of the USA plan and gather for
Holiday dinners
bad day for turkeys good day for
catching up with all their relatives
close friends and their friends
the three generations of family gathered
around the dinner table in Norman
Rockwell's famous painting Freedom from
Want surely thought all the same
thoughts as one another and all the same
issues that confronted them in 1943
today however family dinner
conversations commonly devolve into a
cage match of verbal combat what were
once calmly held opinions are now
tribalized and weaponized
dinner guests Express their views as
unassailable truths to be defended at
all costs complete with fork pointing
accusations of being socially culturally
or politically clueless about everything
that matters in society
are you woke
if so are you open enough or are you too
woke did you vote for Trump twice how
about Obama
he'd vote for him twice
what do you sleep with whom do you pray
to do you pray at all what bathroom do
you use what countries do you favor
which ones do you hate do we send in the
military should we have a military at
all do you love guns do you Embrace law
enforcement and the justice system
like the Supreme Court do you watch Fox
News or MSNBC
I guarantee that during this year's
holiday dinners some of all of those
topics will be raised and tested
consider what happens when scientists
disagree
we look for one of three outcomes
either I'm right and you're wrong
you're right and I'm wrong or we're both
wrong that's an implicit contract we
carry into all arguments on the frontier
of Discovery who decides the outcome
nobody does
arguing more loudly or strenuously or
more articulately than your opponent
simply reveals how annoying or obstinate
you are the resolution almost always
comes when more or better data arrive
here are a few examples of calm rational
analysis that might take place in a
scientist's head
an exercise and thinking out loud
but with training to seek and evaluate
not both sides of an argument but all
sides while sensitized by Leonardo da
Vinci's edict the greatest deception men
suffer is from their own opinion
one
do you love all animals
if yes does that include ticks fleas
leeches and mosquitoes
if any of these parasites were
endangered would you lead a movement to
protect them they're animals too just
try to make a living like the rest of us
they just don't happen to be furry
not into bloodsuckers then confess to
yourself that you want to protect only
cuddly cute animals
invoking a form of species bigotry upon
the Tree of Life
two
do you eat lime caught tuna
if so that protects air-breathing
dolphins that might otherwise get caught
in Nets where they suffocate and die
tragic indeed personally I seek outline
caught tuna for that reason but amid the
outpouring of Sympathy for the dead
dolphin and all the lobbying to save
them where is our Collective concern for
the dead tuna
three but dolphins are mammals Gotta
Love mammals we're we're mammals yet
last I checked sore Lambs pigs and cows
and we eat them maybe a dolphin's big
brain relative to its body size is what
we value
we surely respect elephants and whales
for that reason
but the animals with the largest to
brain body weight ratio far exceeding
that of humans are various species of
ants logging up to 15 of their body
weight and brain matter come to think of
it they do have huge heads in the U.S we
don't eat ants but for reasons that have
nothing to do with their big brains
4. what about political troops we all
know that Republicans are pro-family
values but the lowest divorce rate in
the country by far the is the
perennially blue state of Massachusetts
and nine of the ten states with the
highest divorce rate voted read in the
2020 election
further if you analyze childbirths
you'll find that nearly half of all
babies born in Louisiana Alabama
Mississippi Texas Oklahoma Arkansas
Tennessee Kentucky West Virginia and
South Carolina are born out of wedlock
yet each of these states voted red in
every general election this century
the corresponding rates for the famously
blue states of California Minnesota
Massachusetts and New York are half that
so conservatives cannot claim The High
Ground when it comes to family values
five another political trope
liberals Embrace science while
conservatives reject it
indeed the denial of human-caused
climate change poses an existential
threat to civilization
and that sits squarely within Republican
rhetoric yet liberals were the original
vaccine deniers
liberal enclaves also contain Crystal
healers astrologers a homeopathic
medicines as well as strong anti-gmo and
anti-farma sentiments
to absorb these lines of thinking
requires you reject some or all
mainstream science related to them so
liberals cannot claim The High Ground
when it comes to who does or does not
Embrace science
[Music]
nearly every thought every opinion and
every Outlook I formulate on world
affairs has been touched informed and
enlightened by knowledge of our place on
Earth and of our place in the universe
far from being a cold Fearless
Enterprise there's perhaps Nothing More
Human Than methods tools and discoveries
of science
they shape modern civilization
what is civilization if not what humans
have built for themselves as a means to
transcend Primal urges and as a
landscape on which to live work and play
what then of our Collective and
persistent disagreements
all I can promise is that whatever
opinions you currently hold an infusion
of Science and rational thinking can
render them more informed than ever
before
but that path can also expose unfounded
perspectives or unjustified emotions you
may carry
that's when many disagreements suffer
While others simply evaporate leaving
you with nothing to argue about in the
first place
[Music]